my concern is that the people of
Northern Ireland themselves are very
self-critical uh and in my remarks uh to
the people of Northern Ireland during
this past week I've tried to emphasize
that there is no Society on Earth that's
free of violence there's no Society in
Earth that's free of disputes and
disagreements so it don't not have more
self-confident more confidence in this
place it's a great place it's a
beautiful place
and the people are energetic and hard
working so the only real comment or
message I want to deliver is you are
great people you can do better we all
can do better
and you can be better and we all can be
better